el contacto de la lava volcánica con el
agua salada del océano es tan mortal
como tóxico para el ecosistema marino y
terrestre cuando el magma o roca fundida
sale del volcán en forma de erupción la
incandescencia líquida se expande en la
superficie y luego se enfría y
solidifica pero cuando la fuerza de la
lava logra llegar hasta el mar la unión
de estos dos componentes produce una
reacción química altamente nociva
y al llegar al agua y
lo que está ocurriendo es que la elevada
temperatura que tiene la lava en este
caso del orden de los 900 grados
provoca una rápida ebullición del agua
marina así que lo que vamos a tener es
una gran cantidad de vapor de agua
y también algunos gases algunos de los
cuales tienen niveles de toxicidad
elevada el fenómeno mata inmediatamente
a los animales que viven en el fondo
marino y que no se pueden mover además
afecta al ser humano pues el ácido
clorhídrico de los gases irrita las vías
respiratorias y la piel y gases que son
inyectados en la estratosfera y que por
esa causa producen
algunos inconvenientes tales como
lluvias ácidas o incluso decrece un
poquito la temperatura media global
el contacto de la lava con el agua de
mar es una de las grandes preocupaciones
para las autoridades por las
repercusiones que puede tener en la
salud del ser humano y los daños que
deja en los litorales